il vous accueille en personne disparue
depuis dix ans raymond devos a légué ses
souvenirs réunis en un musée au sein
même de sa demeure une volonté de
l'artiste la mairie à l'époque légataire
universel aller pour mission de mettre
en place une fondation qui elle-même
mettra en oeuvre tout ce qu'il fallait
pour l'ouverture d'un musée dans sa
maison le but des aménagements de ce
musée sont d'en faire un lieu de vie
vidéo et audio puisque ça correspond au
caractère de l'artiste était raymond
devos dans cette maison achetée en 1963
remond devons aussi créer ses sketches
une atmosphère décliné dans les
différentes pièces du musée dans ce
musée on peut voir les pièces maîtresses
en tant que pièce architecture
c'est-à-dire son bureau qui a été
reconstitués d'après photos et son petit
musée les autres pièces maîtresses ce
sont les
distinction qu'il a reçu les prix qu'il
a reçu et puis tous les objets kim dont
il se servait plus exactement pour ses
sketchs on peut voir dans cette maison
d'abord sa maison on n'y a gardé son
bureau son petit musée la bibliothèque
de sa salle à manger et dans les autres
pièces il y aura des éléments de vidéo
et audio pour voir ses sketches entendre
la préparation des sketches et puis y
découvrir un certain nombre d'objets du
cirque notamment avec lesquels il
habillait ses sketches elle la
maison-musée peaufine son installation
la découverte de la vie de raymond devos
sera possible à partir du 7 novembre